19:12 a german meteorologist named
Alfred Wegener proposed the theory about
how the Earth's landmasses formed he
suggested that the great continents of
the earth had once formed a single
landmass called Pangaea which had broken
up and drifted apart over time he called
this process continental drift and it
went against all conventional thinking
at the time may seem very unpopular
amongst his peers it's a shame because
he was absolutely right
but it would take the work of a young
cartographer called maurice art to help
turn the tide of opposition leading to
one of the greatest paradigm shifts in
the earth sciences and it all began at
the bottom of the ocean
mery father worked for the department of
agriculture and from a young age she'd
join him on his work trips and he
traveled around the country collecting
samples for soil survey like these early
experiences were formative in developing
Mary's interest in geology and after
gaining a master's degree in the subject
she landed a position at Columbia
University in 1947 here she worked as an
assistant to Bruce heezen a geology
graduate who's collecting thousands of
depth measurements across the Atlantic
Ocean during expedition he's and his
team used echo soundings collect depth
data which involves sending out
high-frequency sounds or pings and
recording the time delay of the
returning echoes the data could then be
plotted to build a profile of the
terrain below
unfortunately for thought women were
prohibited from joining these early
expeditions because of a fear that
they'd bring bad looked at sea instead
she remained behind at the University to
process the data converting endless rows
of X measurement into detailed profiles
of the ocean floor
conventional thinking is once believed
that the ocean floors were slapped
featureless plain but start nuts were
beginning to tell an entirely different
story
her profiles reveal the existence of
complex geography of crevices metallic
but perhaps most startling was the
emergence of a long v-shaped cleft that
ran through each of her profiles these
so-called risk valleys offered support
to vengan 'as continental drift theory
if two land masses were moving apart
they'd split the ocean floor in two
carrying the scar in the landscape and
forming a valley below with this
evidence for the controversial theory
start believe so but seasons was
skeptical dismissing many of her
suggestions as Girl Talk nevertheless
Sark was convinced by our findings and
later produced a more detailed
physiographic map to further support her
case at the same time another graduate
student
Howard Foster was plotting the excess
sentence of earthquakes in the same
region of the Atlantic fart notice that
they occurred at the same location as
her proposed ballet and as he expanded
to other areas they found something
interesting where there were mid-ocean
ridges there were also earthquakes so it
seemed as though these two were related
at this point even the skeptical heathen
could no longer deny what they were
looking at a pattern of scars that
spanned the Earth's oceans permanent
wounds torn into existence through the
process of continental drift
the findings were finally reported in
1957 but opposition from the scientific
community was still fierce renowned
explorer Jacques Cousteau was so sure
they were wrong he charted an expedition
to film the ocean floor to settle the
score once and for all but the footage
he brought back did the opposite it
showed the deep valley it showed how it
splits the mid-atlantic ridge in half
and it showed that darks maps were right
all along it was exactly where she
potted it and the evidence mounted the
paradigm shift and the earth sciences
was inevitable
such steadfast determination has paved
the way for begginers continental drift
theory to gain traction and as the tide
of opposition waned
it gave birth to our modern
understanding of plate tectonics and can
cure tarps position as one of the most
outstanding cartographers of the 20th
century
[Music]
[Music]
you